how many options does chemistry really
have many that's the point and the thing
is this is where the origin of life scam
comes in
uh
is that people
don't quite count they don't count the
numbers so if biology as you find on
earth is common everywhere then there's
something really weird going on that
basically written in the quantum
mechanics there's some kind of these
bonds must form over these bonds and
this catalyst must form over this
catalyst when they're all quite equal
life is contingent the the origin of
life on earth was contingent upon the
chemistry available at the origin of
life
on earth
so that means if we want to find other
life like other earth-like worlds we
look for the same kind of rocky world we
might look in the same zone as as as
earth and we might expect
reasonably to find
biological like stuff going on that
would be a reasonable hypothesis but it
won't be the same it can't be it's like
saying
i don't believe in magic that's why i
i'm sure i just don't believe in magic i
believe in statistics and i can do
experiments and and so i won't get the
same exactly the same sequence of events
i'll get something different
and so there is tick tock elsewhere in
the universe but it's not the same as
our tick tock right
that's that's what i mean which aspect
of it is not the same well i just think
you you it
the so what is tick tock tick tock is a
is a social media where people upload
videos right of silly videos so i guess
there might be there's humor there's
attention there's ability to process
this ability for intelligent organisms
to collaborate on ideas and find human
ideas and play with those ideas make
them viral memes
you know uh
humor seems to be kind of fundamental to
the human experience and i think that um
that's a really interesting question we
can ask is humor a fundamental thing in
the universe i think maybe it will be
right in terms of you think about in a
game theoretic sense humor uh the
emergence of humor serves a a a role in
our game engine and so
if selection is fundamental in the
universe and so is humor
well i don't actually don't know exactly
what uh
role humor serves maybe it's like uh uh
from a chemical perspective it's uh like
a catalyst
for uh
i guess it's a several purpose one is
the catalyst for spreading ideas on the
internet that's modern humor but humor
is also a good way to deal
with the difficulty of life
it's a kind of valve
release valve for suffering
like
throughout human history life has been
really hard
and for the people that i have known in
my life who've lived through some
really difficult things uh humorous part
of how they deal with that yeah this is
usually dark humor but
yeah it's interesting i i don't know
exactly sort of the what what's the more
mathematically general way to formulate
what the hell is humor
what humor does it serve but i i still
we're kind of joking here but
it's uh a counterintuitive idea to me
to think that uh
life elsewhere in the universe
is very different than life on earth
and also
like
all of each instantiation of life
is likely very different from each other
yeah like maybe there's a few clusters
of similar like life
but uh it's much more likely is what
you're saying to me it's a kind of novel
thought i'm not sure what to do with it
but you're saying that there's uh
it's more common to be a weird outcast
in the full spectrum of life than it is
to be in some usual cluster so every
instantiation of a kind of
chemistry that results in complexity
that's autonomous and self-replicating
however the how you define life
that is going to be very different every
time i don't know i
it feels like a selection
is
a fundamental kind of directed force in
the universe
won't selection result in a in a few
pockets of interesting complexities i
mean
yeah i
if we ran earth over
again over and over and over you're
saying it's going to come up but
there's not going to be elephants every
time
yeah i don't think so i think and i
think that there will be similarities
and i think we know we don't know enough
about how selection
is um
globally works
um
but it might be might be that the the
elephant
um the emergence of elephants was wired
into the history of earth in some way
like the gravitational force how
evolution was going
cambrian explosions blah blah blah the
emergence of mammals but i just don't
know enough about the contingency right
the variability all i do know is you
count the number of bits of information
required to make an element sorry an
elephant and
and um think about the causal chain that
provide the lineage of elephants going
all the way back to luca
there's a huge scope for divergence
yeah but
just like you said with chemistry and
selection
the the things that result in
self-replicating
chemistry
and self-replicating organisms
those are extremely unlikely as you're
saying
uh but once they're successful they
multiply so like i i just it might be a
tiny subset of all
of all things that are possible in the
universe chemically speaking it might be
a very tiny subset is actually
successful creating elephants
or uh elephant like
or slash human-like creatures well
there's two different questions here's
the first one if we were to reset earth
and to start again
the different phases sorry to keep
interrupting yeah no if we restart earth
and start again say we could go back
back to the beginning and do the
experiment or have a number of earths um
how similar would biology be i would say
that there would be there would be broad
similarities
but um but the emergence of mammals is
not a given unless we're going to you
know throw an asteroid at each planet
each time and go try and try and
faithfully reproduce what happened
then there's the other the other thing
about
when you go to another earth-like planet
elsewhere maybe there's a different
ratio particular elements maybe there's
uh the bom the bombardment at the
beginning the planet was quicker or
longer than earth and and i just don't
have enough information there what i do
know
is that um
the the complexity of the story of life
on earth
gives us lots of scope for variation and
i just don't think it's a reasonable
mathematical assumption to think that
they will the the life on earth that
happened again would be the same as what
we have now
you